WE'RE FOINKING
NEWS OUT OF ISRAEL, THERE   RIGS
ISEI U.SR
ISRAEL, AFTER TODAY'S ATTACK G L
ISRAELIS SO FAR,OU
AEIZ.STIN WH TOP
LITTLE WHILE AGO, INCLUDING THE
.SL COAN
LET'S GET MOREN WHAT IG  RIGHT
NEL IGUS
A
IS WH S WELL
COLONEHTON.
AT DO
DOT NO TO YOLP
DE
DOWN, THERE HAVE BEEN VERY
STRONG STATEMENT
ISH HAMAS?
WE END UP DOING ISORT, IF THE I
THE ISRAELIS WILEDN TERMVEN DIP
EGES PLACE - PERHA
WITH THE LOGISTICS ASPECTSF AND
INGS IN,ER AREAS
ISRAELIS NEED TO HAVE THEIR EP
>> KIMBERLY, AI F TARY SPOKESPEI
ISL ONGOING,M IN MORDIFFERENT L
A MOBILIZED
RESPONSEM >> COMPLICATEDNDNTR
SIIO MILITANTS  WITH ELANE TROOI
BECOMES VERY DIFFICU FISRAELI D
PRY.
THEY'RE ALREADY FACING A MASVEEN
THIS, AND T RESPONDING
ICTHE SOUTH.
WHAT  FD U.S.
OFFICI T IS NOT JUSTTH T THAT TH
MI SIGNSTHIS POTENTIALATTACK, BT
STARD HE
'S WHYS FASTER AND TKETHEM FROM
SEEN THE ISRR P MORE
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO
MEC TONDO  ALL
OFHED HOW THISS PLOTTED OUT, AND
THCURSION INTO GAZ BRINGING A LF
MEANS THEY'LL NEED RESERVIST HI
SE.COLONEL LEL IS
E IZF ISPAGROUNDURSION Q OIOON A
O TH LIKELY SCEN
WOLF,
MENTD,E GROUND
GHHIELAVNE IBEREALLY,
WARFARE. IS THE MOST CROWDED
K NOW ON THE FAC
E  TERMS OE
POPULATION PER SQUARE MILE, ANDE
OF DIFRELL HAVE TO CONSIDER.
THEY WANT TO GO AFTER E , ANIN E
THE HAMAS RGETS, BUT THERE A
GOING TO B W
WILPROBABLY BE COLLATERAL
GOINGMAKET  TOUGH ON THE ELIS,
POINT.
THE OTHER THING OF COURSE, THAT
THISGOING TO USE AIR POWER R TH,
SEEN AROUND GAZA, BUT
THINK THE BOMBING ATTACKS ARE
GO INTENSE AND
EYMORE HAMAS FIGHTEROM
CONGRAELF.
L LEASTOR
NE4  SHOURS.
>> AND KRLT IS ISRAEL TCHEBANK,N
>> WELL, THEY'RE WATCHING FOR
ALLIES SLLRE, WHIC HOW ISRAEE EN
.IND THE MILINTS IN SYRIA.
SSAN 100,000, AN C HEZBOLLAH
MOST OEL WATCHING,RC
WAHIHISPARK SOME SORT OF  INSID.
LAST TWO UPRISINGS, THE  A IN s
FROM A CAR A
TRUCKLOADS OF PALESTINIAN
ANDLE SPA P L
T THENTOOK AINE TRYING TO
IT THE OTHER WAY .
THEY'RE STAGING A BIG SPLASHATC
HEREVER EYCK
ANTE AS
IEL SHARON, THRAADER
E MOUNTKRAED I
CREDIT AREA IN THE OLD
HA LEADER SAID THE
OF RECENT INCURS BI
ULTRA NATIONALIS IE
HEADLINES  OF THE SACRED AR,
SO FROM EIR Y'REG OTHELE, ORDINA